[موسيقى]
وعدت لندن بالتحقيق في وثائق تكشف عن
تعاون استخباراتي بين بريطانيا وليبيا
خلال عهد القذافي شمل هذا التعاون استجواب
اشخاص متهمين بالارهاب لدى الغرب والتضييق
على معارضين للقذافي في
[موسيقى]
بريطانيا
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من
زاويتين ما حجم التعاون بين الاستخبارات
البريطانيه ونظام القدافي وكيف سيتم تعويض
الضحايا ان ثبت سدق ما جاء في
[موسيقى]
الوثائق السلام
عليكم تجد ليبيا ما بعد الثوره نفسها
مضطره للتعامل مع ملفات شائكه نتجت عن 40
عاما من حكم القذافي من بينها ملفات حقوق
الانسان قد يكون التعاون بين اجهزه الامن
والاستخبارات في العالم امرا عاديا وتك و
متكررا وله ضحايا ولكن عندما يكون هذا
التعاون بين طرفين كانت لهما خصومات
سياسيه في العلن وصلت الى حد العداه فان
الامر يحتاج فعلا الى مزيد من البحث عن
الاسباب التي تجعل علاقات الظاهر تختلف عن
علاقات
الباطن تجي قوه اجنبيه تحتل دوله عربيه
وتشنق رئيسها واحنا نتفرج عليهم
ضحكم كانت تلك الصوره الثوريه التي انفق
العقيد القذافي سنوات طويله من عمره
واموالا طائله من ثروات بلاده لرسمها
ليبيا الجماهيريه قلعه النضال الثوري
صاحبه الباع والذراع في مقارعه
الامبرياليه عن العقيد الراحل ايامها نظما
من بين اهمها بريطانيا صوره عصفت بها
وثائق خطيره كشف النقاب عنها في ليبيا
تحكي اسرارا عن تعاون مخابراتي وثيق قام
لاعوام متتاليه بين مخابرات لندن وطرابلس
بعيدا عن ضجيج المعارك الكلاميه التي كانت
تظهر وتختفي بين الجانبين قام العمل
المخابراتي المشترك بينهما نشيطا يتعقب ما
كان الطرفان ينسجمان في وصفه بالعناصر
المتطرفه في اشاره يحيل اغلبها على عناصر
سل
جهاديه قدرت اجهزه البلدين ان من المصلحه
المشتركه تعقبها وتجنيدها في سياق مناهضه
ما يوصف بالارهاب ممارسات تورت فيها كل من
جهازي الامن الداخلي والخارجي في بريطانيا
ام اي 5 وام اي 6 بعلم طبعا من اعلى
القيادات فيهما وسط تاكيدات بان تزكيه هذا
التعاون تتجاوز دوائر القرار الامني في
اعلى مستوياتها الى اصحاب القرار السياسي
ممثله الاساس في وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
الاسبق جاك سترو مسؤول رفع عبد الحكيم
بحاج احد القيادات العسكريه للثوره
الليبيه رفع في وجهه قضيه على خلفيه دوره
المفترض في تعقبه والقبض عليه وترحيله الى
ليبيا حيث تعرض للتعذيب بعد ما كان فارا
من وجه النظام الليبي حكايه بحاج ليست سوى
نقطه في بحر ما تميت الوثائق المكتشفه
اللثام عنه الى الحد الذي بات فيه كثيرون
يتحدثون عن فضيحه امنيه من العيار الثقيل
تشمل في حيثياتها توفير غطاء اداري
ولوجستي ومالي لنشاط عناصر مخابرات
القذافي في بريطانيا ومساعدتهم على
الايقاع بالمستهل من رجال المعارضه وتقديم
النصائح في كيفيه التعامل معهم على النحو
الذي يضمن افضل مستوى من الاستفاده منهم
واذا كانت لجنه الامن والاستخبارات في
البرلمان البريطاني قد وعدت بفتح تحقيق في
الغرض فان الدويه الذي اوقعته الوثائق يعد
بتداعيات سياسيه وقانونيه اكبر واوسع
بريطانيا في ظل غياب العقيد القذافي وسقوط
نظامه معنا في هذه الحلقه من طرابلس كل من
محمد العلاجي رئيس المجلس الوطني للحريات
وحقوق الانسان وانيس الشريف احد الاسماء
التي وردت في الوثائق كما ينضم الينا من
لندن عادل درويش الكاتب الصحفي في صحيفه
الديلي ميل البريطانيه اهلا
بضيوفنا نبدا بالسيد انيس الشريف في
طرابلس ما تجربتك الشخصيه في هذا
الملف
ا يعني
انا كنت اعيش في بريطانيا في العشر سنوات
الماضيه وكنت اعرف ان هناك تعاونا
استخباراتيا ليبيا بريطانيا بعد اتفاق
الصحراء الشهير بين توني بلاير والعقيد
معمار القذافي
لكن ما كشفت عنه الوثائق التي عفوا قلت
كنت تعرف كيف عرفت
عمليا عمليا كنا نعرف ان عن طريق العديد
من الاصدقاء الذين تم محاوله اصطيادهم في
هذه العمليات المشتركه من المخابرات
الليبيه والام اي 6 في ذلك الوقت ومحاوله
استعمال كل وسائل الترغيب والترهيب
لتجنيدهم و راق المعارضه الليبيه في
بريطانيا في ذلك
الوقت على المستوى الشخصي لم اتعرض لهذا
الامر ولكني فوجئت الوثائق انني كنت طوال
الفتره على كل رهن يعني ومعلوماتي الشخصيه
ومعلومات اسرتي في بريطانيا التي احمل
جنسيتها كانت يقوم جهاز المخابرات الام اي
فا ب بتحويله لجهاز الاستخبارات الليبي
الامن الخارجي بما في ذلك كل الاتصالات
التي اقوم بها في ليبيا مع افراد عائلتي
مما كان يعرضهم للخطر في صيف عام 2007
اتصل ب صديق وزميل دراسه من سوريا كان
هاربا من بطش العقيد القذافي وطلب مني ا
بعض المساعده في كيفيه الوصول الى الى
منطقه امنه في اوروبا وطلب اللجوء السياسي
للتامين على حياته اي لل المصادفه انه بعد
ايام انقطعت كل وسائل الاتصال بهذا الصديق
ثم سمعت بعد فتره ان النظام السوري سلمه
الى السلطات الليبيه الان اكتشفنا ان
المخابرات البريطانيه التقطت هذه المكالمه
وقامت بتحويلها الى رقم هاتف في سوريا الى
المخابرات الليبيه التي بدورها اتصلت
بالسوريين فقاموا بترقب واعتقاله وتسليمه
الى ليبيا وبقى في السجن حتى تحرير طرابلس
وتم الافراج عنه ضمن مجموعه كبيره من
السجناء في ال4 من اغسطس عام 2011 من سجن
ابو سليم
الشهير يعني عفوا ا اشرت في البدايه الى
ان اتفاق جرى بين القذافي وتوني بلير
سميته اتفاق ال الصحراء كيف علمت به متى
كان هذا الاتفاق الشهير
الذي توج في زياره توني بلاير في مارس عام
2 وارعه الى خيمه العقيد القذافي الشهيره
وال التي اتت بعد ما اعلن النظام الليبي
انذاك تسليم ما سمي ببرنامج ما لديه من
برنامج الاسلحه الدمار الشامل اي كان ذلك
في اطار الصفقه السياسيه الكبرى في اعاده
نظام القذافي الى الحضيره الدوليه مقابل
اتفاق السلطات البريطانيه والامريكيه
لتسليم القذافي لمعارضيه ومحاوله الحد من
نشاطات المعارضه الليبيه وفيما بعد كان
ايضا هذا الامر داخل في ضمن الصفقه
الاقتصاديه الكبرى للشركات النفطيه
البريطانيه والامريكيه بما في ذلك شركه
الشركه البريطانيه البيبي البيبي
البتروليه نعم سيد عادل درويش في في لندن
هل فوجئت الاوساط البريطانيه بحجم هذه
النوعيه من
المعلومات لا هي الامر لم يكن مفاجاه ال
الا الوضع الاخر الذي تعترض عليه المؤسس
ثلاث مؤسسات في بريطانيا بالتحديد او ثلاث
تيارات التيار الليبرالي
وتمثله الصحافه في ا ا وضع علىما استفهام
حول التعاون مع حكومات غير خاضعه للمحاسبه
الديمقراطيه يعني ماما بيكون هنا في خطا
يرتكب هنا في قوانين في مجلس عموم في
صحافه بتحاسب هذا غير موجود في انظمه
دكتاتوريه كنظام الكلين القذافي التيار
الثاني هو تيار ا طبعا ال الديمقراطي من
نواب البرلمان من مثلم ا تفضل زميل وذكر
من لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه ولجنه الامن في
المشتركه المختاره في مجلس العموم من ان
هذا النوع من المعلومات اي تسليم مشتبه
فيهم ل لسلطات تمارس التعذيب
ا امر يعني
ساذج وغير حكيم لان التعذيب لا يحصل على
معلومات مفيده بقدر ما يحصل على معلومات
يريد المعذب ان يسمعها التيار الثالث طبعا
هو التيار القانوني القضائي والمحامين
وطبعا الى جانب هذا هناك تحقيق بوليسي
بسبب خرق القانون والساد بالحال كما كما
تفضلت وذكرت رفع قضيه على القراف
البريطانيه وعلى وزير الخارجيه السابق
وهذه سياخذ ستاخذ مجراها فهذه هي ولكن سيد
درويش يعني سواء كان التيار ليبراليا او
ديمقراطيا او او قانونيا ان يصل حج حجم
التعاون بين استخبارات بلدين خاصه بين
لندن وطرابلس ليس فقط مجرد تبادل معلومات
وانما التنسيق في القبض على اناس وتسليمهم
هل هذا امر غير مسبوق فيما عرف عن
المخابرات البريطانيه في علاقاتها عموما
مع مع
دول يعني هو هو طبعا اتكبت اخطاء يعني
يعني لو كان هذا الامر هو القاعده وليس
الاستثناء ما كان تثار هذه الضجه ما كان
الخبر يصبح خبر صفحه اولى في الديلي
تيليجراف وما كانت تكون هناك تحقيق بوليسي
وتحقيق في مجلس العموم ف ان هذا الخطا
وهذه المخالفه الصريحه لقوانين
البريطانيه هي التي
جعلت كانت وراء هذه الضقه اي ان هذا كان
استثناء وليس القاعده في التعامل نعم سيد
محمد العلاجي في في طرابلس هل كنتم
تعتقدون بان ان نوعيه العلاقه بين طرابلس
ولندن يمكن ان تتجاوز مجرد التعاون
الاستخباراتي الذي يمكن ان يكون بين بلدين
الى حد التخطيط المشترك او الى حد التواطؤ
كما
وصف والله ليس مستغربا في علاقات
الاستخبارات بعضها ببعض المؤسف هنا حقا
انه انه ليبيا وبريطانيا ما تربطهم ما ب
بلتهم اتفاقيات ثنائيه بشان تسليم
المجرمين
كان في اتفاقيات عقدت في 2008 ربما كانت
هناك انابه قض قضائيه للبحث في
قضيه الشرطيه البريطانيه فليتشر مقابل
انابه قضائيه اخرى او المساعده في الكشف
عن محاوله اغتيال القدافي هذا الذي نعلمه
واعلن هنا
وبالتالي هنا الامر يرقى الى مساله حتى
خلق جرائم محدده بين الاستخبارات ال
الانجليزيه والاستخبارات الليبيه على سبيل
المثال هذه الورقه تقول يتحدثون عن هدف
مقترحات الجانب البريطاني مثلا
تقول يتم الاتصال
به يعرض عليه يعرض مساعدته في حل مشا
مشاكله في ليبيا وبريطانيا مقابل التعاون
في تزويدنا بم بمعلومات في حاله رفضه
العرض يتم القبض عليه من البوليس
البريطاني الذي له تهمه التعامل مع
المخابرات البريطانيه يعني ع يعني عفوا
الليبيون المعارضون في في لندن كانوا
يتعرضون للابتزاز بمعنى ان اما ان يصبحوا
عملاء للمخابرات البريطانيه او يقع
تسليمهم لليبيا هذه الصوره كانت هذه هي
الصوره تماما وهذا
مستند موجود بنسختيه الانجليزيه والعربيه
وباتفاق بين شخصيات استخباراتيه انجليزيه
و وليبيا هنا يصبح البوليس هو الذي يخلق
هذه الجرائم اما ان يقبل التعاون معه واما
ان ان ان يتهم بتهمه التعامل مع المخابرات
الليبيه ويسلم الى ليبيا طبعا القانون
الليبي لازال وحتى في السابق يعرف عقوبه
الاعدام المساله اخلاقيه بالدرجه الاولى
يعني حتى اتفاقيات
التسليم بين ال اتفاقيات التعاون القضائي
وتسليم المجرمين لا تشمل القضايا السياسيه
والجرائم السياسيه والجماعه الاسلاميه
المقاتله ان شئت وغيرها من التجمعات كانت
معارضه ليبيه لم تكن مجموعات ليست
مجع ترى ان يتغير النظام ا بال بالقتال
داخل ليبيا فهي معارضه ولم تكن حركه
ارهابيه توجه نشاطها الى الى الى خارج
ليبيا الجماعه الاسلاميه المقاتله
دفعت الكثير وحبت ثم ولجات الى كما
تحدث
اشرف انه عند الجنسيه البريطانيه ومع ذلك
زملاء هناك
يبتزون لموقفهم هذا هو التعاون
الاستخباراتي لي بالانجليزي والذي بصراحه
اسقط في يده انا لما شفت اتفاقيات بهذا
يعني اعرف انه هناك تعاون وتجاوز للقانون
لكن هناك مسائل اخلاقيه لا يمكن ان هناك م
مسائل اخلاقيه والان هناك ايضا مسائل
تداعيات قانونيه لما بعد هذه الاتهامات
بالطبع اذا ما تم التاكد منها بشكل قاطع
هناك حقوق هناك تعويضات هذا الجانب الذي
سنتطرق اليه بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها التعاون
الاستخباراتي البريطاني الليبي غير
المسبوق ايام حكم الزعيم الليبي الراحل
معمر القذافي سيد عادل درويش في في لندن
عندما تاتي ال وزاره الداخليه البريطانيه
وتقول بانها لا تعرف التفاصيل تفاصيل هذه
القضيه ولكنها تاخذها على محمل الجد
وستحقق في الامر الا نشعر بان هناك
استمرار ل استغباء الراي العام
تقريبا لا هو شوف في مشكله اساسيه في عند
المسؤولين في البيروقراطيات العريقه يعني
بتج هذه المشكله موجوده بيروقراطيه زي مصر
مثلا بجها موجوده
في في روسيا موجوده في بريطانيا بشكل كبير
جدا وهي ان موظفي الدوله كما تعلم هنا في
فصل بين الحكومه والدوله الحكومه بتتغير
بالانتخاب والدوله ثابته موظفي الدوله
الثابتين دائما يعني عندهم ولع كبير
بالسريه بشكل قد يستحق العرض على دكتور
سيكولوجي طبيب
نفساني فهم يعني يعني لما ظهرت مثلا قضيه
بالحج كان المفروض ان يقولوا والله يا
جماعه احنا كنا تردنا
لارهاب وكان هناك تعاون واحنا مضطرين بعد
هذه الاحداث الارهابيه واحنا اخطئنا
ونعتذر لكن هم حاولوا يغطوا هذا الخطا
بنوع من السريه فهذه الطبقات المختلفه من
السريه حتى بتحول احيانا دون ان يتمكن
الوزير الوزير بيبقى منتخب من الشعب في
حين ان هؤلاء الموظفين ثابتين لا ينتخبون
ولا يتغيرون فحتى الوزير بيجد صعوبه او
الوزيره بتجد صعوبه في كشف هذه المعلومات
فهذه بالفعل مشكله حقيقيه فيما بنسميه
وايت هول اللي هو مباني الدوله البريطانيه
وطبعا تعاون دائما الصحافه بتح حاول تكشف
البرلمان بيحاول يكشف لكن في النهايه الذي
يعني يحتوي في مكاتبه هذه الملفات
والارشيفات والكلام ده كله هم هؤلاء
المجموعه من خدم التاج الذين من الصعب جدا
اختراق حجز السريه بتاعهم هو هو بلا شك
سيد درويش صوره بريطانيا ك كمنفى محترم
ربما تكون اهتزت بهذه المعلومات ولكن فيما
يتعلق بصوره بريطانيا كنظام قضائي هؤلاء
اذا ما رفعوا قضيه مثل علي بحاج ضد جاك
سترو القضاء يمكن ان يذهب فيها بشكل
جريء طبعا القضاء هو افضل افضل واشرف قضاء
في
العالم سواء في في انجلترا وويلز او في
اسكوتلندا قضاء مستقل
تماما قضاء
يعني يعني ربما انتم تتابع ابو قتاده
المطلوب للعداله باحكام غيابيه في الاردن
متهم بالارهاب هنا 10 سنوات كلف دافع
الضرائب وعلى فكره المحامين الذين يفون
عنه يدافعون على حساب دافع الضرائب
البريطاني هو لا يدفع مليم واحد ويتناول
اعانه هو واسرته وقيم مجانا ورغم سالك 10
سنوات بسبب القضاء يحكم بقضاء فاصل كامل
تعجز الحكومه عن وضع عنط على طائره ه هل
ربما هل ربما سيكون سيكون هل ربما وهنا
نسال سيد انيس الشريف هل ربما سيكون
الحال ستكون الحالات الليبيه ربما بهذا
المستوى يعني مثلا انت شخصيا هل تعتزم ال
الشكوى او رفع الامر الى
القضاء يعني الكثير من من من وردت اسمائهم
في هذه
الوثائق يعني يعتزمون الاتصال بالمحامين
في الايام القليله القادمه ل لاخذ المشوره
القانونيه وا اذا كانت بالايجاب فبالتاكيد
سخ يرفعون دعاوه قضائيه ضد الاستخبارات
البريطانيه اي يعني لكن اريد ان اشير هنا
الى نقطتين الاولى قضيه التحقيقات الرسميه
يعني
هناك شعور بعدم جديه الحكومه احيانا في
كشف هذه الامور وبان هذه التحقيقات
الرسميه تستخدم ك كغطاء للتغطيه على ما
يتم ارتكابه من تحت الطاوله ونحن في
بريطانيا لاحظنا كل التحقيقات التي حصلت
بعد الحرب على العراق و حتى الان لم تخرج
بادانه شخص واحد او شخصيه سياسيه او
استخباراتيه او امنيه واحده لذلك ال يعني
من يريد ان يطالب بحقه فربما ستكون هي عن
طريق المحاكم البريطانيه التي لازال فيها
جانب كبير من العداله التي يمكن ان تحقق
القضيه الثانيه التي اريد الاشير اليها ان
ما حدث هو خرق كبير لتقاليد بريطانيا في
في قضيه في وعرف بريطاني وهو اللجوء
السياسي وقبول اللاجئين يعني ما تم الان
الامر لا يتعلق بعمليه لا وجود اتفاقات
لتبادل المطلوبين ولا غيره يعني ما تم هو
عمليه بيع لهؤلاء الناس الذين جاؤوا الى
برطانيا وطلبوا فيها اللجوء طلبا للامن ان
يتم بيعهم ومحاوره تسلمهم والعمل مع عدوهم
الذي هربوا منه والانظمه الديكتاتور
النظام الدكتاتوري الذي هربوا
منه يتعاون الامن البريطاني مع هذا العدو
المستبد لمحاوله اختراقهم وبيعهم والضغط
عليهم وعلى عائلاتهم يعني ما حدث وسابقه
في في تاريخ بريطانيا وخق كبير وهو ما يع
خرقا لقانون جنيف للجوء السياسي ولقانون
ولقانون حقوق الانسان وايضا لقانون سريه
المعلومات في بريطانيا مثلا انا طالب وجدت
في احد الوثائق ان الجانب الليبي طالب
صوره حديثه لي من الجانب البريطاني فقامت
فوجدت بعد ذلك انهم زودو بصوره شخصيه
قدمتها عندما قدمت طلبا للحصول على جواز
السفر يعني تم اخذها من من الطلب من صوره
وبعثت الجانب ليبي هذا ما يعد اختراقا
وكسرا لقانون حمايه المعلومات الشخصيه
المعروفه في بريطانيا مثلا نعم وما جرى مع
الليبيين ربما قد يكون حصل ايضا مع
المصريين مع الاردنيين مع التونسيين ربما
هذه القضيه ستثير بدورها قضايا اخرى نسال
محمد العلاجي في نهايه
البرنامج ما نوعيه المساعده التي يمكن ان
تقدموها لهذه الحالات من المواطنين
الليبيين الذين تعرضوا لهذه
المظلمه
انضم لانيس فيما ذهب اليه والان نتحدث على
الجانب القانوني بعد الجانب الاخلاقي الذي
لا يمكن ان يتخيل ان الاختراقات تكون بهذا
المستوى انا ايضا اذهب مع السيد عادل
درويش ان القضاء البريطاني القضاء عنده
تقاليد وقضاء محترم
الحقيقه ما ما ما ما هو موجود في ليبيا من
وثائق بين من من
الاستخبارات بين الاستخبارات البريطانيه و
ا الليبيه يكفي وحده لاي محكمه مدنيه ان
ان ان ان تدين وتقضي وتقضي بالتعويض
لهؤلاء الضحايا الحقيقه
يعني الادله موجوده اي
اي يعني ه هل هل مثلا هل مثلا ستكلف
محامين على نفقه الحكومه الليبيه ربما
للتكفل بهذا الموضوع هي مساله ليبيه طبعا
هؤلاء المواطنين الليبي لابد من ان من ان
تساعدهم الدوله الليبيه في اختيار محامين
وفريق دفاع على مستوى عالي من الكفاءه هذه
وجهه نظري الا اذا ارادوا هم ان يختاروا
محامين اخرين فتلك مساله اخرى مثل هذه
القضايا الحقوقيه تجد متطوعين من العالم
اجمع اعتقد انها لا تشكل مساله كبيره
مساله اتعاب المحامين اي لكن ما اريد ان
اقوله انه الحقيقه عمد احكي بالحاج جلب من
بانكوك في كيس يعني حتى طريقه التعامل
والله الواحد اي يتاسف انا كرجل حقوقي
اتاسف تماما لما حصل له وما كان يمكن ان
يحصل لهؤلاء في ظل هذه الاتفاقيات السريه
التي الحكومه البريطانيه تدعي والنظام
الليبي انهم اعداء وما الى ذلك لكن الذي
يحدث
تحت الطاولات اتفاقات كثيره اذا كان حدث
هذا في بريطانيا شكرا شكرا شكرا لك اذا ما
ما تحت الطاوله اكثر بكثير ما هو فوقها
يعني شكرا لك السيد محمد العلاقي رئيس
المجلس الوطني للحريات وحقوق الانسان في
ليبيا شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من لندن عادل
درويش الكاتب الصحفي في صحيفه الديلي ميل
البريطانيه وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من ليبيا
انيس الشريف احد الاسماء التي وردت في
الوثائق التي تم الكشف عنها مؤخرا عن
العلاقه المخابراتيه البريطانيه الليبيه
بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه في امان
الله